naja also wenn man jetzt das alles so
zusammenfasst ergibt sich ein puzzle was
man sie jetzt lesen kann
zum ersten mal also die ganzen fragen
die vorher offen waren wie die
russischen ärzte auch reagiert haben wie
navalny am 20 august halt in im flugzeug
zusammengebrochen ist dann behandelt
wurde
das zeigt wie gefährlich nur wittstock
ist und das schließt aus puzzle ich will
anfangen damit novy job kann erst mal
verabreicht werden ein hochgiftiger
kampfstoff was wir gehört haben ein
chemischer kampfstoff kann durch
inhalation verabreicht werden also man
kann es ein atmen durch indizierung oder
man kann es auch transdermale
verabreichen sprich es ist geht durch
die haut das heißt ein kontakt reich ich
kann es irgendwo bestreichen das heißt
eine türklinke reicht oder eine
zufällige begegnung mit einer mir
unbekannten person die fast mich an und
ich bin kontaminiert das sind alles
verabreichungsform und offenbar ist es
so dass es in geringster dosierung schon
zu diesen furchtbaren erscheinung kommen
kann bis zum tod eben ganz schnell was
man jetzt eben weiß ist das als navalny
im flugzeug halt enorm zusammengebrochen
ist haben die russischen ärzte die erste
reaktion
bloß nicht anfassen isolieren schauen
das sind so diese typischen diagnosen
und nur wittstock ruft der verlegung der
atemwege schaum vorm mund also da haben
die vermutlich schon gemerkt hat
erscheint fast nicht zustimmen dann
kamen die russischen offiziellen von den
nachrichtendiensten und auf einmal war
es ein blutzucker abfall oder ist eine
stoffwechselkrankheit eine mögliche also
das ganze wurde derartig bagatellisiert
wo selbst vermutlich die russischen
ärzte den kopf geschüttelt haben dann
ist er nach deutschland gekommen und
hier in der charité haben die ärzte eben
relativ schnell festgestellt dass es
sich um ein gift handelt ein nervengift
weil eben die entsprechenden organe
betroffen waren
und das ist eben jetzt die große frage
wie
ist eben weiter geht und wenn man
bedenkt dass russland mehrere tonnen von
diesem gift hat das ist nur wie job 7
vermutlich dann und das ist hochgiftig
dann weiß man wie gefährlich es ist es
ist natürlich wie ein fingerabdruck
dieses gift man weiß wo es herkommt